monsieur le
président
la séance est
reprise nous allons dans quelques
instants aborder les questions au
gouvernement chacun sera attentif au
respect des uns et des autres et au
respect du temps de parole je n'ai pas
su reçu d'observation mais ce matin ça a
été examiné sur la précédente séance je
vais vous demander de de vous
lever mesdames et messieurs les
ministres c'est avec tristesse que nous
avons appris le 25 novembre dernier
disparition de Gérard Colom Gérard colon
nous a quitté au terme d'un combat
contre la maladie qu'il menait avec un
grand courage ce matin même ces obsèques
se sont déroulés en la cathédrale
Saint-Jean de Lyon en présence du
président de la République et de madame
la Première ministre qui va nous
rejoindre lors de cette cérémonie
d'adieu à laquelle assistai de nombreux
habitants de sa ville et de son
département ainsi que nombreuses
personnalités politiques l'émotion éta
c'est'est présente Mathieu Darnaud notre
premier vice-président y représentait le
Sénat figure emblématique de la capitale
des Gaules Gérard Colomb voit sa voit sa
vie entière à un engagement inlassable
au service de ses compatriotes et de
l'intérêt général ses facultés d'écoute
son esprit de solidarité ét unanimement
salué et suscité le respect son élection
en 2001 à la mairie de Lyon restera le
moment privilégié de sa vie publique il
se consacrera à sa ville durant plus de
17 ans grâce à lui Lyon fut capable de
rivaliser avec les autres métropoles
françaises et européennes sans pour
autant perdre son âme il transformera sa
ville et mettra toute son énergie au
service de ses de ses
habitants énergie qu'il mettra aussi au
service de la communauté urbaine de Lyon
dont il fut le président il fut aussi
parlementaire élu député dans la 2e
circonscription du Rhône c'était en juin
1981 il avait 34 ans son arrivé au Sénat
en novembre
1999 marquera sa vie politique il sera
réélu en 2004 et en
2014 il siégea au sein du groupe
socialiste à présidé par Claude Estier
il devint membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles toujours tourné
vers la modernité il est en 2007
l'auteur d'une proposition de loi
relative à la coopération internationale
des collectivités territoriales dans le
domaine des technologies de
l'information et des communications en
2009 il intégra la commission des lois
où ses collègues d'alors peuvent
témoigner de sa connaissance des
dossiers touchant aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
il intervint dans notre hémicycle à
propos de la loi de modernisation de
l'action publique territoriale et
d'affirmation des métropoles c'était en
juin 2013 à propos des compétences de la
métropole de Lyon et ce fut je le sais
un temps majeur de sa vie de
sénateur après avoir été l'un des
principaux soutiens d'Emmanuel Macron il
est nommé ministre d'État ministre de
l'Intérieur dans le gouvernement
d'eddouard Philippe il porte devant le
Sénat le projet loi renforçant la
sécurité intérieure et la lutte contre
le terrorisme visant à transposer dans
le droit commun certaines mesures de
l'état d'urgence et défend en 2018 le
projet de loi sur l'asile et
l'immigration il doit affronter
l'attentat islamiste de trève il mesure
le danger du communautarisme qui ronge
notre pays lors de son départ du
ministère de l'Intérieur il laisse ce
message je le cite aujourd'hui on vit
côte à côte je CRA que demain on vive
face à face c'est à
méditer l'hommage que nous lui rendons
aujourd'hui n'est pas uniquement
solennel c'est aussi un hommage à un
humaniste un hommage à un défenseur
alinçable de sa ville Lyon et de la
métropole à ses anciens collègues
j'exprime notre sympathie à son épouse à
qui j'ai écrit à ses enfants à toute sa
famille à tous ceux qui ont partagé ses
engagements je souhaite redire la part
que le Sénat prend à leur chakra et je
vous demande d'observer un moment de
recueillement
je vous
remercie madame la Première ministre
j'avais annoncé votre décalage lié à
votre retour de Lyon merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs ce matin autour de sa famille
et de ses proches
autour du président de la République
autour des habitants de sa ville nous
avons dit adieu un grand
républicain un liyonnais passionné et un
homme d'État Gérard colon était un
modèle de réussite
républicaine rien ne le prédestina ni à
diriger sa ville ni à d'éminentes
fonctions
ministérielles pourtant sa passion pour
les lettres sa force de travail et la
puissance de ses convictions lui ont
permis de devenir enseignant député
sénateur ministre d'État ministre de
l'Intérieur et bien sûr maire Gérard
Colomb a été l'homme d'une ville pour
Lyon il avait un amour réel sincère
inébranlable arpenté sa ville s'est
croisé à chaque coin de rue ses projets
ses idées ses intuitions il s'est donné
cors à sa ville et la transformer les
liyonnais ne l'oublieront jamais Gérard
colon c'était encore un homme de
conviction porté par la volonté de
servir au-delà des clivages porté par
l'attention au problèmes des Français
plutôt qu'aux étiquettes politiques le
Sénat chambre des territoires et de
l'apaisement lui correspondit bien et
chacun dans la majorité présidentielle
sait ce qu'il lui doit ad augusta per
angusta vers les voies célestes par des
chemins étroits c'était une de ses
devises aujourd'hui Gérard Colomb a
rejoint ses voix célestes mais son
empreinte restera il a changé la vie des
Lyonnais il a changer la vie des
Français je vous
remercie
merci madame la Première
ministre je vais donner la parole à
notre collègue Cédric chevalier pour le
groupe les indépendant République et
territoire merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous nous
réjouissons profondément que etane HERZ
et SAA français et aotage du Hamas et pu
retrouver leur famille leur libération
est un premier pas qui suscite un
immense
soulagement en premier lieu madame la
ministre pouvez-vous nous informer sur
l'état de santé de ces enfants âgés de
12 à 16 ans après ces semaines de
captivité je voudrais en second lieu
rappeler que parmi les 1200 civiles tués
lors des attaques du 7 octobre 40
d'entre eux possédaient la nationalité
française nous ne devons pas oublier nos
compatriotes
assassinés parmi les sur vivant des
dizaines d'otages sont toujours aux
mains des terroristes et parmi eux c
français les familles sont depuis
confronté à une incertitude
insoutenable à ce sujet je tiens à à
rendre hommage aux agents de notre corps
diplomatique qui travaillent
d'arrachepied avec leurs collègues
d'autres pays pour obtenir la libération
des otages encore captifs madame la
ministre disposez-vous de renseignement
à leur sujet pouvez-vous nous donner de
leur nouv ou enfin la trêve entre Israël
et le Hamas a été prolongée jusqu'au 30
novembre il est permis d'espérer que ce
soit un signe favorable à d'une
désescalade que vous avez publiquement
appelé de vos vœux même si nous n nirons
pas que les négociations sont très
difficiles madame la ministre que
pouvez-vous nous dire de ces discussions
et des perspectives qu'elles ouvrent je
vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à
madame la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères madame Colona vous
avez la parole monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur chevalier
etan RS SAR vous avez évoqué leur nom et
vous avez bien fait t la libération de
ces trois enfants français est un
immense soulagement pour nous tous et
vous savez que la libération de nos
compatriotes retenu en otage est la
priorité numéro 1 du président de la ré
République et de notre diplomatie je
veux remercier à nouveau comme le
président de la République l'a fait
comme la première ministre l'a fait tous
ceux qui ont œuvré pour cette libération
et je pense en particulier au Qatar à
Israël bien sûr à l'Égypte notamment et
jour après jour croyez-le nous avons été
actifs et mobilisés comme eux pour
obtenir ce résultat je vous remercie
d'ailleurs de ce que vous avez dit à
propos de nos agents diplomatiques et
consulaires
nous avons partagé parfois souvent
l'inquiétude des familles aujourd'hui
nous partageons maintenant euh leur joie
mais c'est aussi une joie mêlée de
douleur en pensant à ce que ces enfants
ont vécu en pensant que s'ils sont
désormais en sécurité et avec leur
famille ce qui leur est arrivé est
proprement inhumain et ceci doit nous
rappeler quelle est la vraie nature du
Hamas une organisation terroriste et
dénué de tout
scrupulle aujourd'hui nous poursuivons
nos efforts tous nos efforts sous la
conduite du président de la République
et nous restons pleinement mobilisés
pour obtenir la libération de tous nos
compatriotes retenus en otage nous ne
relâcherons pas nos efforts vous le
savez car la France n'abandonne jamais
les soins nous souhaitons avec votre
aide souhaitons publiquement à haute
voix depuis plusieurs semaines que la
trêve qui est en cours puisse être
prolongée qu'elle amène la libération de
tous les otages et qu'elle soit un
premier pas amenant d'autres pas positif
menant aussi vers un cisser le feu car
il faudra bien qu'il y ait une solution
politique c'est celle à laquelle nous
travaillons et celle à laquelle nous
devons travailler tous ensemble avec nos
partenaires sans délai aucun il y a
effectivement urgence merci aussi de
l'avoir rappelé je vous
remercie monsieur
chevalier notre collègue Ahed lawedge
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social
européen monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre de la
ville et de la citoyenneté permettez-moi
tout d'abord d'exprimer une pensé pour
Thomas à sa famille à ses amis et à tous
ceux qui l'ont connu et aimé les
sénateurs de mon groupe adressent les
plus sincères
condoléance sa disparition est une
tragédie il est tentant dans ces
moments-là de céder à la colère à la
peur et à la division il est tentant de
chercher des Bou émissair et de
stigmatiser mais c'est précisément ce
que veulent ce qui cherchent à nous
opposer les uns aux autres tous ceux qui
ont pour seul horizon la division
rapidement l'extrême droite a
instrumentalisé l'affaire de Crépol et
une ultra droite décomplexée a pris le
relais dans les rues de plusieurs villes
de France madame la ministre avec 1300
fichiers s ces grospuscules représentent
la deuxième menace terroriste en France
il faut que tous nos concitoyens
mesurent ce danger
face à cela les dissolutions de Milic ne
suffiront pas au combat contre la haine
ces milices renaissent de leurs cendre
car les idées restent c'est donc aussi
la bataille des idées qui éloera notre
pays du risque de bataille rangé restons
vigilant et déterminés aidons les jeunes
à tous les de tous les territoires à se
réapproprier les principes républicains
un axe qu'apporté ici le RDSE la semaine
dernière à travers son texte sur la
citoyenneté nous devons aussi avoir
confiance à la justice en ses
représentants et en sa capacité à
maintenir la paix sociale dans un état
de droit c'est la justice qui doit
rendre la justice madame la ministre une
certaine catégorie de la classe
politique a soufflé sur les braises de
la violence il y a urgence à agir nous
vous demandons de condamner sans
équivoque les discours de haine et de
division nous avons un devoir d'unité
face à une société fragmentée où le lien
social est rompu où le vivre ensemble
est sérieusement menacé par toutes les
minorités violentes Madame le Ministre
comment comptez-vous empêcher les
prochaines expéitions envisagées par
l'ultra drroite merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État chargée de la
citoyenneté de la ville madame gristi
roubach merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur Ahmed laoued je
mercie infiniment pour votre question et
un mot sur le jeune Thomas tous les mots
que nous pourrons prononcer les uns et
les autres ne seront jamais à la hauteur
de la perte pour ses parents et pour le
pays donc je poursuis juste en excusant
si vous voulez bien excuser le ministre
de l'Intérieur et des outres maires
Gérald armanin vous avez raison de
m'interroger sur les mouvements d'ultra
drroite qui ont mené en réalité ces
derniers jours des action coup de point
dans plusieurs villes de France et vous
avez raison cela menace notre vivre
ensemble profondément face à cela nous
nous ne cesserons de le répéter nous
condamnons avec la plus grande fermeté
les groupescules d'extrême droite qui
prétendent se substituer au policiers au
gendarmes pour se faire justice eu même
je vous l'assure la réponse de l'État
sera implacable face à ces porteurs de
haine qui ne cherchent qu'à nous diviser
nous n'hésiterons pas à dissoudre des
associations et groupesouscules
d'extrême droite s'il le faut comme nous
l'avons toujours fait avec Génération
identitaire par exemple le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outresmers proposera
notamment lors du prochain conseil des
ministres la dissolution du de la
division Martel ce groupuscule infemme
des forces de l'ordre sont également
pleinement mobilisées pour interpeller
les auteurs de ces de ces troubles à
l'ordre public les traduire devant la
justice et prévenir de nouvelles actions
violente à roman sur iser comme à Lyon
de nombreuses interpellations ont eu
lieu mettre fin à ces manifestations
sauvages qui ne véhiculent que la haine
de l'autre je rappelle également que 1
attentats d'ultra drroit ont été déjoués
depuis 2017 par nos services de
renseignement vous vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur l'État ne transige
pas avec avec ça avec ce sujet
gravissime pour la désunion de notre
nation vous me trouverez toujours à vos
côtés avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
tout le gouvernement le président de la
République et toutes les forces
républicaines pour les combattre et je
voulais juste vous dire un un dernier
mot sur ce sujet tous ceux qui pensent
qu'en réalité là ils ont fait une
récupération politique ils ont fait une
récupération infemme d'un notre âge d'un
notutre temps et j'ai honte pour eux je
vous remercie monsieur le
sénateur la parole est à notre collègue
Sébastien fen pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues mort au bououle c'est
avec ses trois mots peints sur le
portail de la mosquée que les habitants
de charerbau en Cotentin se sont
réveillés samedi dernier ces menaces de
mort sont intolérables ces mots sont ABS
et d'une grande violence ils ont suscité
un émoi légitime dans notre ville peu
habitués aux expressions de haine pour
reprendre les mot de l'un des fidèles de
la mosquée en écrivant cela il nous
menace physiquement mais il cherche
aussi à à nous exclure de la communauté
nationale en effet au travers de ces
menaces c'est bien notre communauté
nationale dans son entièreté qui est
touché et meurtrie hélas les actes vécus
samedi dans la Manche ne sont pas isolés
dès le printemps dernier notre collègue
Jérôme Durin alerté et proposé une
résolution dénonçant les violences
commises par l'ultradroite car depuis
des mois ces violences se multiplient
partout dans notre pays saint-billeux
Saint-Brévin lespins et bien d'autres et
pas plus tard qu'hier ce sont des
croixgamés qui ont été couverte sur la
façade de la mairie de Lunas dans
lesérau depuis la mort tragique du jeune
Thomas àpol nous constatons une
recrudescence de ces actes des individus
peu scrupuleux utilisent un drame qui
nous atteint toutes et tous pour mettre
à exécution leur obsession d'une guerre
civile et ethnique dans ce climat de
grande tension nous déplorons
sincèrement que le chef d'un grand parti
républicain se refuse à condamner
l'expédition punitive menée à roman
surizer par des militants d'ultradroite
nous devons prendre la pleine mesure de
notre responsabilité historique quand la
cohésion nationale se fissure sous les
saillis d'une violence débridée quand la
Concorde républicaine est menacée par
les défilés de groupuscules fascisant
aucun républicain sincère ne doit
manquer à l'appel nous devons plus que
jamais veiller à préserver la fraternité
républicaine devant la recrutesence des
actes racistes antisémites et
antimusulmans qui menacent notre unité
madame la ministre comment comptez-vous
faire front contre la haine et restaurer
l'ordre républicain face aux menaces et
aux violences de l'ultr
droite madame la secrétaire d'État en
charge de la citoyenneté de la Villez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur votre question
porte
également sur les agissements récents de
l'ultradroite je tiens ici tout d'abord
à fermement condamner au nom du
gouvernement l'État graciste àosé sur la
mosquée de
Cherbourg je veux affirmer mon plein
soutien et celui de l'État à No
à nos compatriotes de confession
musulmane de ce département touché par
ces actes auieux ces croix cellti qui
ont notamment été tagué symbole comme
vous le savez emblématique de l'ultr
drroite en ce sens j'entends votre
inquiétude légitime monsieur le sénateur
mais soyez rassuré la République est et
sera toujours intransigente avec ses
milices comme l'a précisé le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outresmèes une
enquête est en cours et les forces de
l'ordre sont d'ors et déjà à pied d'
durant et depuis tout ce weekend pour
retrouver les auteurs de ces
dégradations racistes parce qu'il faut
dire les mots afin qu'il puisse être
présenté devant la justice monsieur le
sénateur vous le savez le respect de
toutes les croyances est inscrit à
l'article 1er de notre Constitution et
s'impose à tous jamais nous ne
laisserons monsieur le sénateur ces
mouvances d'ultra droite piétiner notre
cohésion nationale nous n'abandonnerons
pas nos compatriotes de confessions
musulmanes qui vivent sereinement leur
foi dans le respect des valeurs de la
République nous ne et je ne me
résignerai jamais nous ne cèderons
jamais à ce qu'il soit la cible de ces
groupuscules identitaires qu'un seul
objectif et je le dis et je le répète le
chaos par la guerre de tous contre tous
c'est ça leur objectif si on pouvait
éviter de se marrer quand je parle c'est
bien la République leur fera face
partout où ces derniers s'aimeront leur
idéologie mortifère infâme et encore une
fois d'un notre âge je vous remercie
[Musique]
merci la parole est à
Monsieur Yan brossa pour le groupe
communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste monsieur brossa vous
avez la parole merci merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre nous avons
tous en tête l'effroyable assassinat de
de Thas 16 ans qui a créé chez les
Français une profonde émotion une
émotion sincère une émotion légitime
nous avons aussi vu dans les minutes qui
ont suivi alors que le sang de Thomas
était encore chaud une ignoble tentative
d'instrumentalisation
d'instrumentalisation organisée par
l'extrême droite qui s'est livré à un
racolage électoral
répugnant nous avons entendu nous avons
entendu madame maréchal Le Pen parler
d'une guerre ethnique nous avons entendu
monsieur Zemmour parler d'une guerre de
civilisation nous avons entendu Marine
Le Pen dire les petits blancs contre les
personnes de couleur ce sont les mots et
puis ensuite il y a eu les actes il y a
eu les événements dans ce quartier
populaire de roman sur iser avec des
individus cagoulés armés de bares de fer
qui étaient là pour casser du noir et de
l'arabe ces groupes là je veux le dire
ce ce ne sont pas des ozau ce sont des
ennemis de la République ce sont des
néonazis qui doivent être combattus
comme des ennemis de la République parce
que face à eux la République doit se
défendre et elle doit se protéger pour
protéger la Concorde
républicaine vous nous avez annoncé et
c'est tant mieux la dissolution d'un
certain nombre de groupes d'extrême
droite et nous nous en félicitons il
reste que derrière il y a des hneur
d'ordre qui ont micro ouvert sur un
certain nombre de chaînes de télévision
pour répandre leur Bill raciste c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous le demande
madame la ministre quand est-ce que le
gouvernement va se saisir de la
proposition de résolution des
parlementaires communistes qui vise à
rendre inéligible les auteurs de propos
racistes et antisémites il est grand
temps pour vous répondre la parole est à
la secrétaire d'État chargée de la
citoyenneté de la ville merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur brossin
vous m'interrogez également donc sur les
exactions récentes de l'ultradroite vous
avez raison l'ultradroite est un danger
un danger permanent contre la République
et les valeurs universelles qu'elle pte
en elle nous devons tous unanimement
condamné avec la plus grande fermeté ces
groupuscules identitaires qui ne cherche
qu'une chose l'affrontement les
Irlandais ont pu notamment constaté les
dégâts et la dangerosité ces derniers
jours en ce sens monsieur le sénateur
nous n'avons on pas attendu ces derniers
jours pour prendre cette menace au
sérieux et pour la traiter au degré à
laquelle elle doit l'être à ce titre les
forces de sécurité intérieure ont déjoué
très attentats d'ultra drroite depuis
2017 je le rappelle ici près de 1300
personnes sont fich S et donc suivi par
nos services s'agissant de ces récentes
manifestations sauvages nos forces de
sécurité intérieure ont été largement
mobilisé dans les enquêtes menant à
l'interpellation de ces individus
violents c'est également ce gouvernement
monsieur le sénateur qui a dissous sur
proposition du ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outres mères de multiples
associations
ou
groupement de fait s'inscrivant dans
cette mouvance ultraviolente Gérald
Armanet a pu d'ailleurs annoncer hier
matin que trois autres groupuscu ferait
l'objet d'une procédure de dissolution
je parlais à l'instant de la division
Martel dont le nom vous le concèderez
nous donne une certaine idée du projet
violent fantasmé par ces
individus ils en feront partie monsieur
le sénateur brossa quel que soit
l'extrême l'ultra droite l'ultra gauche
sont des poisons pour notre démocratie
ils doivent être combattu avec fermeté
et c'est ce que nous faisons en
remettant ces individus à la justice en
dissolvant des grusc des groupuscules
tenté par l'ultraviolence contre nos
concitoyens je vous remercie la parole
est à notre collègue Anne-Catherine
leoisier pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche des tirs en rafale se sont fait
entendre dans le quartier Stalingrad à
Dijon ces tirs d'armes de gros calibre
sur un immeuble visaient non pas à
intimider mais à tuer les cibles étaient
vraisemblablement de jeunes dealer
installés dans l'entrée bien connue de
cet immeuble les jeunes ont pris la
fuite sans être touché mais une balle a
atteint un homme qui dormait dans son
lit au premier étage depuis à Dijon ce
sont les mêmes émotions qu'anim en
dernier après le décès d'un jeune garçon
de 10 ans ou à Marseille en septembre
après celui d'une jeune femme de 24 ans
l'incompréhension tout d'abord comment
peut-on être tué chez soi par une balle
perdue la douleur et la peur de ne plus
être en sécurité soi et sa famille
jusque dans son domicile et enfin la
colère car semble-t-il tout le monde
connaissait ce point de Deal l'usage
grandissant des armes et l'insécurité de
ce quartier alors madame la ministre
face à l'augmentation de 57 % des des
homicides des tentatives entre 2022 et
2023 face à l'ampleur des trafics qui
gangrenent nos quartiers mais aussi nos
campagnes quelles sont vos
réponses pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'État en char de la
citoyené de la ville vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
loiser vous l'avez rappelé dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche un père de famille
de 55 de 55 ans a été tué par balle dans
son sommeil à son domicile j'ai une
pensée sincère pour sa famille elle a
perdu un proche victime collatéral d'un
règlement de compte sur fond de trafic
de drogue lorsqu'un point de dile est
particulièrement visé et harcelé par les
services de police et de gendarmerie
comme celui de Dijon nous le savons les
règlements de compte et les batailles de
territoire redoublent de violence l'État
ne reculera pas pour éradiquer le trafic
de drogue le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outres MRES Gérald armanin a
immédiatement déployé et envoyé la crs8
à Dijon ces renforts resteront autant
que nécessaire dans l'agglomération de
Dijon les services de l'État sont
totalement mobilisé autour du préfet
pour lutter pieds- à pied contre le
trafic de stupéfiants grâce au
déploiement de moyens extrêmement
importants depuis le début de l'année
dans le département de la Côte d'Or 1252
opérations ont été conduites 2, tonn 2,4
tonnes pardon de stupéfiants saisis 368
interpellations ont été opérées au plan
national ce sont 14410 opérations de
démantèlement de points de deal qui ont
été menées avec donc en hausse de 30 %
par rapport à 2022 face au trafic de
drogue qui grandraine nos quartiers le
gouvernement déploie des moyens d'agir
mais il faut aussi être intraitable à
l'encontre des consommateur car sans
consommateur et je l'ai dit plusieurs
fois il n'y a pas de trafic il n'y a pas
de dealer madame la sénatrice soyez
assuré que le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outremèes et l'ensemble du
gouvernement M tout en œuvre pour lutter
efficacement contre ce fléau que sont
les que sont la délinquence ces fléau
que sont la délinquence et le trafic de
stupéfiants je vous remercie madame
Loisier oui je vous remerci madame la
ministre al moi je voudrais profiter de
l'occasion effectivement pour saluer les
initiatives de Monsieur le Préfet Robin
et l'intervention de la CRS 8 venu faire
place net mais un certain nombre de
questions se posent encore que se
passera-t-il après car au-delà d'une
opération coup DEP la population de ces
quartiers elle a besoin d'une présence
dans la durée pour s'assurer qu'elle ne
se retrouvera pas seule face à ces
bandes violentes donc quel dispositif le
gouvernement pense-t-il mettre en place
en ce sens les forces de lordord
effectivement font un travail
remarquable mais nous le savons les
effectifs des brigades spécialisées sont
insuffisantes dans nos territoires les
consommateurs vous en avez parlé ne
serait-il pas temps de relancer des
campagnes sur la sensibilisation
peut-être même de revoir les amendes
forfaitaires pour les rendre plus
dissuasives et enfin la réponse pénale
nous le savons tous n'est pas à la
hauteur de ce phénomène elle inquiète de
plus en plus nos concitoyens elle
décourage les policiers et les gendarmes
et nourrit ce sentiment d'impunité des
délinquentss la parole est à notre
collègue Yanic jade pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoire
monsieur le
Président avant de poser ma question
j'aimerais rendre hommage à une
infatigable écologiste notre collègue
député européenne Michel Rivasi qui est
disparu dramatiquement et brutalement ce
matin madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues demain débute la code 28
à Dubaï et c'est peut dire que les
engagements climatiques des États sont
insuffisants nous nous dirigeons vers un
réchauffement planétaire de 3 degrés
deux fois plus que les engagements pris
à Paris en
2015 l'effondrement climatique a
commencé l'humanité est en train de se
suicider ce sont les mots du Secrétaire
général des Nations Unis justement pour
les Nations unies pour l'Agence
internationale à l'énergie pour les
scientifiques du GC une seule solution
maintenant engager la sortie des
énergies fossiles en commençant par
stopper tout nouveau projets de charbon
de pétrole de gaz ce devrait être la
seule boussole du président Macron à
Dubaï et madame la Première ministre de
votre gouvernement en France justement
comment allez-vous empêcher le projet de
gaz de houille en Mosel pouvez-vous nous
assurer aujourd'hui devant le Sénat que
vous allez bloquer le projet funeste de
nouveau forage de pétrole à La Teste de
bûche en Gironde la même où 7000
hectares de forêt sont partis en fumé
l'année dernière du fait des
gigantesques
incendies pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Yannick
jado vous me permettrez d'avoir moi
aussi une pensée pour Michel
Rivasi et et pour les conditions
dramatiques dans lesquelles elle nous a
quitté le 30 décembre 2017 c'est sous
cette majorité que la France a décidé
d'interdire tout nouveau projet
d'exploitation d'hydrocarbures sur son
sol ça n'est ça n'a pas été fait
auparavant même quand il y avait des
écologistes au gouvernement ça a été
fait sous le premier quinquena par la
loi du 30 décembre 2017
l'engagement qui a été pris par la
France c'est la sortie de toute
exploitation d'hydrocarbures sur notre
sol au plus tard en 2040 ce que vous
évoquez à la thèse de bûche c'est un
renouvellement de concession ce
renouvellement de concession il n'est
pas aujourd'hui empêché par la loi il a
fait l'objet d'une enquête publique
entre le 28 août et le 26 septembre sans
d'ailleurs qu'aucun Riverin ne manifeste
de remonter au sujet d'un
disfonctionnement ou d'une nuisance
j'excuse agè panirunaché c'est son
portefeuille c'est davantage la
responsabilité du ministre de la
transition écologique de la transition
énergétique que celui de la transition
écologique mais il gélargit le propos on
se contente pas de poser ça en face il y
a une stratégie parce que dire qu'on va
sortir des énergies fossiles c'est bien
regardez comment on le fait c'est mieux
et ça suppose de s'appuyer sur deux
piliers accélérer les énergies
renouvelables ça a été le sens de la loi
qui a été votée et relancer un programme
nucléaire monsieur le député monsieur le
sénateur
pardon personne ne doute de la sincérité
de convictions mais il y aurait
davantage de légitimité de votre part à
être aussi engagé sur la sortie des
hydrocarbures si vous ne vous réfugiez
pas derrière une position idéologique de
refus du nucléaire qui conduit nos
voisins l'Allemagne en particulier pas
seulement à ne pas totalement tourner le
dos fossile mais à réouvrir des mines de
charbon à un moment il faut choisir la
sortie des hydrocarbures c'est une
stratégie en investissement c'est celle
que nous
portons monsieur monsieur jade donc on a
bien compris pour commencer à sortir des
énergies fossiles on continue à forer et
aller chercher du pétrole décidément la
France n'est pas à la hauteur du
rendez-vous du climat l'État français a
déjà été condamné deux fois pour une
action climatique il y aura peut-être
une troisième mais la France Monsieur le
Ministre c'est aussi nos entreprises
total énergie est au second rang mondial
des énergéticiens qui vont le plus
investir sur le pétrole et sur le gaz
BNP Paribas et créd agricole font partie
du top 10 des banques qui financent le
plus ces bombes climatiques il est temps
monsieur le ministre de les sanctionner
en taxant leur sur profit en supprimant
toute tête publique crédit d'impôt
exonération de cotisation dont elle
bénéficierait monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre on ne mène pas la
bataille du climat en signant des
armistices avec ceux qui le
détruisent
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à la présidente Dominique
Estrosi Sasson pour le groupe les
républicains ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères et porte sur
l'accord commercial avec le mercosour
nous n'avons jamais été aussi proche
d'un accord peut-être à de semaines
c'est ce qu'a déclaré lundi à Bruxelles
la présidence espagol du Conseil de
l'Union voilà de quoi faire bondir nos
concitoyens en particulier nos
agriculteurs qui risquent une nouvelle
fois d'être les dindons de la farce d'un
processus politique qui désaisit les
parlements nationaux faire rentrer
presque 100000 tonnes de bœuf de plus
sur le marché européen c'est faire en
sorte que notre agriculture subisse une
concurrence déloyale et pourtant le
Président de la République avait dit
qu'il ne pourrait pas y avoir d'accord
tant que nos concurrents ne
respecteraient pas les mêmes contraintes
de production environnementale et
sanitaire le Brésil c'est presque trois
fois plus de pesticides qui donc épendu
à l'hectare et je ne parle même pas du
risque de déforestation importé ni même
des poulets aux médicaments la voilà à
l'approche de la COP 28 demain j'en
appelle à un minimum de cohérence alors
trois questions madame la ministre quand
où en sommes-nous dans la mise en œuvre
de véritables clauses miroir et dans le
contrôle de nos importations est-ce que
la France va s'opposer à cet accord s'il
est présenté en l'état et enfin
aurons-nous l'insigne honneur en nos
qualités de parlementaires de pouvoir n
prononcer sur sa
ratification pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame m la présidente Estrosi Sass je
vous remercie de votre question car elle
offre l'occasion de rappeler que la
France défend une politique commerciale
équilibré équilibré qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'elle doit être
au service de notre souveraineté
économique et qu'elle doit aussi nous
permettre de sécuriser et de diversifier
nos chaînes d'approvisionnement elle
doit aussi évidemment je vais y revenir
être en ligne avec nos exigences en
matière de développement durable
s'agissant donc du projet d'accord entre
leu et le mercosour les exigences de la
France sont claires et je les répète
volontiers nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
pouvons pas accepter l'accord tel qu'il
a été négocié en 2019 il doit être
complété par des engagements
additionnels
contraignants contraignant et ambitieux
sur le développement durable en
particulier sur le respect effectif de
l'accord de Paris et sur la lutte contre
la
déforestation nous portons nous avons
porté nous continuons de porter cette
position auprès de la comm ion
européenne celle-ci travaille avec les
États du mercosour qui ne sont pas
pleinement Unis vous le savez madame la
Présidente pour que ces garanties
supplémentaires soi apporté et je
précise qu'elles sont à nos yeux
indispensables nous devons aussi
garantir davantage de réciprocité dans
le respect des normes européennes par
les producteurs des paystiers et nous
souhaitons là aussi que les propositions
européennes soient complétées lorsque
c'est pertinent dans le plein respect
des règles de l'OMC par ce qu'on appelle
des mesures miroir elles permettront
d'assurer que les efforts consentis par
nos agriculteurs européens ne soient pas
remis en cause par des importations de
produits provenant de pays qui ne
respecteraient pas les mêmes normes de
production qui auraient des normes moins
exigeantes que les nôtres ce qui serait
tout à fait inacceptable et donc je vous
confirme volontiers madame la Présidente
les exigences de la France sans le
respect de ces exigences il ne saurait y
avoir d'accord je vous
remercie madame la
Présidente je vous remercie merci Madame
la Ministre votre réponse n'est pas pour
autant très rassurante vraiment défendez
les intérêts de la France il y a
quelques jours l'Australie a refusé de
conclure un accord avec l'Union
européenne parce qu'elle considérait que
cet accord ne respectait pas et qu'il ne
qu'elle ne pourrait pas le défendre
devant ses éleveurs je pense que vous
devez en faire de même au niveau de la
France et que vous devez faire en sorte
que véritablement la voie de la France
compte autant que celle des autres pays
il en va bien évidemment de notre
souveraineté et si vous ne voulez pas
que demain l'ensemble de du peuple mais
aussi ses représentants soit encore plus
brutalement braqué contre le libre
échange et contre l'Union européenne
agissez madame la ministre et défendez
les intérêts de la
France la parole est à notre collègue
Frédéric Buval pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendants monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ma question porte sur le bilan d'étape
du SIOM que préside madame la Première
ministre et qui se veut la traduction
opérationnelle de l'engagement de
monsieur le Président de la République
de renouveau pour les outres maire ce
sont 72 propositions concrètes pour
améliorer le quotidien lutter contre la
vie chè et donner des perspectives à nos
compatriotes ultramarin ainsi le
ministre des délégués aux utres maires
adressé cette semaine un inventaire de
l'avancée du SIOM en présence des
acteurs institutionnels de chaque
territoire ultramarin et en dépit de
quelques malentendus regrettables nous
ne pouvons que saluer la volonté
manifeste de coconstruction du
gouvernement pourutant des inquiétudes
demeurent sur le territoire qui portent
tant sur la forme que sur le fond sous
la forme d'abord il est impératif de
rassurer les soci professionnels par la
mise en place rapide d'échang et de
concertation tion avec l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques de terrain sur le
fond maintenant les sujets aussi
délicats tels que le troit de ma ou la
cdpnaf devrait être abordé avec
précaution si une réforme de
simplification et de la vie de tous
nécessaire elle doit se faire en prenant
le temps le temps d'évaluer les
conséquences et d'écouter les élus
locaux pour prendre en compte les
spécificités de chaque territoire et
bâtir des solutions adaptées et
différenciées et d'ailleurs des mesures
plus fortes sont attendues notamment
pour la prochaine étape du sium et vous
connaissez mon engagement personnel sur
des sujets comme la jeunesse ou
l'environnement et particulièrement les
sargas à Martinique les sargas sont une
réalité quotidienne pour les élus des
zones Coutières pour les acteurs
économique mais surtout pour les
habitants des rivages souillés qui en
plus des éménations perdre régulièrement
leurs petits électros ménagers alors ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur l'avenir
du sium afin que nous puissions ensemble
transformer le territoire d'outrem et
leur permettre de se projeter pleinement
dans l'avenir je vous
remercie
merci la parole est au ministre délégué
en charge du renouveau démocratique
monsieur
Veron merci Monsieur le le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
les sénatrices les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Frédéric Buval je vous remercie
pour votre question j'excuse l'absence
du ministre chargé des outr maire ça va
me donner l'occasion quand même de
réaffirmer au nom du gouvernement
l'engagement de travailler en
transparence en concertation pour
améliorer le quotidien des ultramarins
ce que nous voulons c'est une
coconstruction productive le ministre
des outres m recevra lundi prochain 4
décembre l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques ultramarins pour un point
d'étape sur les mesures économiques
contenues dans le sium c'est une
séquence 3h environ qui sera l'occasion
pour chacun de poser des questions
soumettre des propositions dans le cadre
des réformes à venir auxquelles les
acteurs économiques seront bien
évidemment associé sur la réforme
annoncée de l'octroi de ma comme le
ministre a eu l'occasion de le confirmer
la semaine dernière il s'agit de faire
baisser les prix des produits de grande
consommation et de garantir les
ressources et collectivités et protéger
la production locale je le redis devant
cette assemblée aucune réforme n'a été
préécrite
elle se fera dans la concertation avec
les élus ainsi qu'avec le monde
économique
c'est pour cela que les préfets
constitueront dans les prochains jours
des groupes de travail dans chaque
territoire afin de recueillir des
propositions le prochain bilan d'étape
du sium qui devrait se tenir fin février
début mars 2024 sera ainsi l'occasion de
faire un point de situation sur les
propositions formulées et de commencer à
définir les premières modalités de cette
réforme importante sur la question du
CDPF et
LEF
pardon pardon et comme vous le
savezuformme est une mesure de
protection qui s'applique au territoire
à enjeu autant dans l'Hexagone que dans
l'outre mer dans les outrem néanmoins il
est vrai que les territoires ultramarins
sont intégralement soumis à la vie
conforme ce qui peut questionner nous
allons réfléchir avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes pour faire évoluer la
doctrine même si aujourd'hui les
positions des acteurs sont divergentes
je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jacqueline Eustache brigau pour le
groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre hélas aujourd'hui
force de constater après l'expédition
punitive dramatique de crépool qu'il y a
bien de France qui s'oppose d'un côté
une France qui a basculé dans une viol
lance gratuite une France où l'ivresse
de la barbarie est le résultat d'une
éducation défaillante d'un refu
d'accepter nos valeurs une France hors
tout souvent bibronné à l'argent public
ou parfois vivant de trafic minoritaire
certes mais revendicative et
omniprésente et l'autre France une
France paisible respectueuse des lois de
l'autorité une France civilisée qui aime
s'amuser s'instruire s'engager appr
prendre une France tolérante généreuse
et ouverte d'esprit qui subit
quotidiennement l'autre France
face à ce constat aussi désolant que
préoccupant nous méritons mieux que des
leçons de morale ou des procès en
stigmatisation ou en récupération
politique les Français n'acceptent plus
ce dénis qui ne fait qu'accentuer encore
davantage le fossé creusé entre ces deux
Frances vos litanies ne font qu'atiser
les rencœurs le sentiment d'injustice et
favorisent l'inquiétante envie de se
faire justice face à face nous y sommes
quand le gouvernement va-t-il enfin
écouter ceux qui n'ont qu'une seule
volonté l'unité de notre pays et la paix
civile pour vous répondre la parole est
au porte-parole du gouvernement Monsieur
Olivier Veron monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieur mesdames les
sénatri messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice estage
brigot quand on pr l'unité de la France
on ne peut pas dire qu'il y aurait deux
Frances qui s'opposeraient l'une à
l'autre
il y a madame la sénatrice une France
celle des villes celle des champs celle
des cités celle des cœurs de ville une
seule France unie et dans cette France
il y a des délinquants et les
délinquants il faut les traquer il faut
les sanctionner il faut les punir et il
faut prévenir la population des actes
délictueux qui peuvent être commis par
des délinquants à crpol où je me suis
rendu ce sont des délinquants qui ont
attaqué de manière grave et qui ont tué
le jeune Thom et blessé des habitants de
cette commune de crépool et des
alentours qui étaient venus se
rassembler pour faire ce qu'on fait de
mieux en France s'unir dans la fête et
dans la joie j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire à crpol ce n'avait ce n'était pas
une Rix c'était une attaque et il y a eu
meurtre et le motif de bande organisé a
été retenu par le procureur de sorte que
le suspect présumé de l'assassinat du
jeune Thomas est possible de la prison à
perpétuité ce que je suis allé dire à
crpol c'est que l'État de droit il est
fort il est ferme il est le même pour
tout le monde
aucune aucun facteur potentiellement
aggravant ne sera éludé rien ne sera
caché je salue l'action déterminé des
forces de police et notamment de la
gendarmerie une mobilisation de 150
hommes a permis ce qui est rarissime en
moins de 3 jours d'interpeller neuf des
prévenus dont 7 avait prévu de partir en
Espagne pour prendre la fuite madame la
sénatrice personne nignore et personne
ne ni une partie de nos compatriotes une
grande partie de nos compatriotes qu'il
soi dans les villes qu'il soit aussi
dans les dans les champs ont peur face à
la violence qui peut déferler mais je
voudrais dire aussi madame la sénatrice
que ceux qui ont peur et ceux qui vivent
cette violence au quotidien sont les
habitants mêmees des quartiers dont sont
souvent issus les délinquants et c'est
aussi vers eux que nous devons avoir nos
pensées parce que c'est aussi pour eux
qu'il faut rétablir la paix républicaine
et la concorde ils font partie de cette
France unie indivisible à laquelle je
suis sûr vous tenez et que nous
protégeons et à laquelle nous
tenons
madame l'OM engendre la colère monsieur
ministre que nous n'ayons pas la même
notion de la lucidité les morts de
Samuel Paty Dominique Bernard Lola Enzo
Thomas sont des faits de société c'est
une réalité l'impunité le même temps et
votre aveuglement nous ont conduit à
ignorer une France qui aspire clairement
à l'autorité la fermeté et le respect
diriger gouverner c'est avoir du courage
de la cohérence c'est ne pas céder aux
minorités c'est accepter d'écouter enfin
cette majorité silencieuse qui n'en peut
plus et qui ne veut plus subir essential
les citoyens de ce pays comme l'a fait
le garde saau hier est inacceptable
réveillez-vous tant qu'il est encore
temps la parole est à notre collègue
Laurence Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste merci Monsieur
président dimanche nous avons été
bouleversé par un triple infanticide
commis dans le Val de Marne un père a
tué de ses mains à son domicile ses
trois petites filles qui étaient âgé de
4 à 11 ans cet homme avait été en 2021
condamné pour violence sur conjoint et
violence sur mineur une de ses filles il
avait été condamné à 18 mois de prison
dont 12 avec surcis à sorti d'une
interdiction d'approcher au même moment
sa femme avait déposé une plainte pour
viol conjugal bien entendu classé sans
suite comme le plus souvent quand il
s'agit de viol conjugal depuis le
printemps
2023 la femme et les enfants n'étaient
plus protégés ni par l'interdiction
d'approché ni par une ordonnance de
protection les parents étaient en
instance de divorce ils avaient organisé
une garde alternée la mère est allée
deux fois au commissariat signaler des
problèmes lors de la remise des enfants
au pères voilà je voudrais savoir madame
la Première ministre quelle conclusion
vous tirez de ce drame sur l'efficacité
de nos politiques de lutte contre la
violence contre les enfants et les
femmes pour vous répondre à la parole
est à Madame Auror berger ministre des
solidarité de la
famille merci monsieur monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la ministre Laurence
rousignol trois petites filles ont été
assassinées elles avait 4 10 ans et 11
ans trois enfants ont donc été
assassinés je m'étendrai évidemment pas
sur une enquête en cours mais vous savez
qu'elle est et évidemment je l'espère en
tout cas qu'elle sera extrêmement claire
sur les décisions qui doivent être rendu
mais vous interrogez plus largement sur
l'attitude à conduire celle du
gouvernement celle des parlementaires
dans le cadre de l'organisation
notamment des droits des parents des
droits de visite des parents à partir du
moment où il y a un conflit et notamment
quand il y a eu des violence il y a une
proposition de loi vous le savez qui a
été adoptée avec le soutien du
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale par
votre collègue Isabelle Santiago cette
proposition de loi elle permet de poser
des principes je crois qui sont clairs
et qui sont essentiels sur la question
de l'autorité parentale et de la
possibilité du retrait de l'autorité
parentale à partir du moment justement
où il y a non pas des I Mais où il y a
une plainte qui a été déposée retrait si
c'est je crois la question sur la
manière avec laquelle on le sait parfois
la question de la garde des enfants
peut-être un levier entre les parents de
chantage et aussi un levier pour ensuite
pouvoir continuer à exercer une pression
notamment sur les mères notamment sur
les femmes jusqu'à malheureusement ce
qui a pu vraisemblablement se produire
dans votre département dans le Val de
Marne encore une fois la capacité de
cette proposition de loi de permettre la
suspension de toute autorité parentale à
partir du moment où l'un des parents est
poursuivi pour un crime ou pour un délit
et je crois essentiel la proposition de
loi elle va même plus loin puisqu'elle
va jusqu'au retrait au retrait de
l'autorité de l'exercice parental quand
un parent a été condamné pour un crime
ou un délit sur son enfant et elle va
aussi plus loin sur la question des
violences conjugales pour enfin
reconnaître que l'enfant est aussi
covictime des violences conjugales qui
ont été perpétrées à l'encontre de la
mère ou à l'encontre du parent qui les
aurait vécu je sais qu'il y a des pas
essentiels à franchir encore je crois
que cette proposition de loi permet de
franchir une étape qui sera je crois
essentielle dans la protection que nous
devons à l'ensemble de nos enfants et
j'aurai enfin monsieur le Président
pardon pour le délai une pensée pour la
mère de ces trois petites filles qui va
devoir survivre et vivre avec le drame
absolu qui s'est
produit madame
r madame la ministre de vos réponsesz
vous en 2020 2021 2022 à chaque fois
j'en ai eu l'occasion j'ai défendu ici
des amendements pour allonger
l'ordonance de protection de 6 à 12 mois
j'ai défendu des amendements pour
suspendre le droit de VI d'hébergement
dissimuler l'adresse de la mère et des
enfants pendant l'ordonnance de
protection à chaque fois ces amendements
ont été rejetés et par le gouvernement
et par la majorité sénatoriale alors
voyez-vous après le meurtre d'aras après
le meurtre terroriste d'aras le ministre
de l'Intérieur avait dit le ministre de
l'Intérieur avait dit si ma loi sur
l'immigration avait été adoptée sans
doute ce meurtre n'aurait pas été commis
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser que
si ces amendements dont je vous parle
avaient été adoptés ces enfants
n'auraient pas été dimanche dernier au
domicile de leur
père la parole est à notre collègue
George naturel pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
avant de prendre la parole pour la
première fois dans cet hémicycle rendre
hommage à mes prédécesseurs dans cette
assemblée je pense à DQ k Simon loucotte
ilar vandgou Pierre Frogier et Gérard
poadjard ils ont chacun d'eux défendu
inlassablement le maintien de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans la République
française mon action parmi vous
s'inscrira dans cette même volonté
garder la Nouvelle-Calédonie au sein de
notre
République ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre la
Nouvelle-Calédonie collectivité
spécifique de la République se trouve
aujourd'hui à un carrefour décisif de
son histoire le processus de
décolonisation
encadrée par les accords de Matignon et
de néin a engagé la Nouvelle-Calédonie
sur la voie d'une autonomie accrue
respectueuse de son identité propre et
sa place unique au sein de la
République le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outremires rendent tout juste de son
5e déplacement en
Nouvelle-Calédonie je veux ici saluer
l'engagement de votre gouvernement dans
le dossier calédonien le dégel du corps
électoral constitue une impérieuse
nécessité car c'est une étape
essentielle à la tenue d'élection
provincial juste et représentative c'est
pourquoi madame la Première ministre ma
question est double quand allez-vous
procéder au dégel du corps électoral
pour les prochaines élections
provinciales les dizaines de milliers
d'électeurs calédoniens exclus du corp
électoral provincial veulent savoir
quand et comment comment ils deviendront
des citoyens calédonien à part entière
quand auront lieu les prochaines
élections provinciales ces élections
sont capital pour l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et il est essentiel
que leur organisation soit irréprochable
pour assurer la légitimité du processus
démocratique
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur George
naturel vous l'avez rappelé aujourd'hui
le processus politique prévu par
l'accord de numea est allé à son terme
et les Calédoniens ont choisi de rester
français depuis plusieurs mois le
président de la République et le
gouvernement s'emploie à organiser un
dialogue serein et constructif avec les
indépendantistes et les non
indépendantistes c'est la condition pour
dessiner ensemble l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et nous le devons à
tous les Calédoniens notamment la
jeunesse calédonienne qui a besoin de
perspective pour réussir la méthode de
mon gouvernement ne change pas nous
voulons un dialogue avec toutes les
parties prenantes quelle que soit leur
conviction la main de l'État est
toujours tendue y compris pour ceux qui
parfois s'éloignent de la table des
discussions nos objectifs eux non plus
ne changent pas nous voulons parvenir à
un accord sur l'avenir institutionnel de
la
Nouvelle-Calédonie le gouvernement a
fait des propositions qui servent de
base aux discussions mais néanmoins je
veux je veux le redire clairement les
prochaines élections provinciales
devront avoir lieu avec un corps
électoral dégelé c'est une exigence
démocratique et c'est ce qu'à rappelé le
ministre de l'Intérieur et et des
outremes Gérald armanin lors de son
déplacement en Nouvelle-Calédonie la
semaine dernière les discussions doivent
donc se poursuivre pour parvenir je
l'espère à un accord politique mais dans
le même temps le gouvernement avance le
Conseil d'État a été saisi pour préciser
les conditions juridiques d'évolution
des règles en matière électoral et fin
décembre nous proposerons les textes
nécessaires au dégel du corp électoral
et au report des élections provinciales
quoi qu'il en soit ces élections se
tiendront en 2024 monsieur le sénateur
avec mon gouvernement nous cherchons un
accord global sur le dégel du corps
électoral bien sûr mais aussi sur la
citoyenneté calédonienne
l'autodétermination le statut et les
institutions dans ce contexte je compte
sur l'esprit de responsabilité de chacun
pour que les discussions soient menées
dans un esprit d'ouverture il en va de
l'avenir de la Nouvelle-Calédonie je
vous remercie merci madame la Première
ministre la parole est à notre collègue
Joceline guidez pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des solidarités et
des familles l'annonce du vote d'une loi
grand âge avant la fin 2024 est une
bonne nouvelle il est urgent de tenir
les engagements pris pour s'occuper
dignement des personnes âgés vulnérables
et des professionnels qui les
accompagneent pour répondre aux besoins
de nos aînés il est indispensable aussi
de financer le ratio de H professionnels
pour 10 personnes âgées en établissement
comme il aurait dû l'aidre depuis 2012
et comme le préconise la défenseuse des
droits la Cour des comptes et le Haut
Conseil de l'âge enfin pour encourager
le virage domiciliaire il est primordial
d'accompagner les personnes à domicile
dans l'ensemble de leurs besoins au-delà
de la toilette et du ménage j'appelle
votre attention sur la situation
économique et la pénuie en ressources
humain dont pâtissent les établissements
et services pour personnes âgées les
récentes enquêtes sont préoccupantes et
alertent sur des difficultés d'une
ampleur inédite la survie de certains
établissements et servic est en jeu face
à la gravité de la situation il est
nécessaire de prendre des mesures fortes
et de long terme pour éviter la faillite
de certains établissements et services
acteurs indispensables de
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées ma
question est simple comptez-vous
répondre à cette situation d'urgence au
travers d'une loi pluriannuelle pour le
grand si oui quand comment et avec
quelle mesures concrètes quels sont les
contours de votre plan grand âge et
autonomie nous espérons une réponse
engagé je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre des
solidarité de la famille madame berger
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice guidez je vais essayer de
répondre de manière engagée donc parce
qu'en 2030 un Français sur 3 aura plus
de 60 ans et parce que pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de notre pays les
plus de 65 ans vont être plus nombreux
que les moins de 15 ans c'est donc un
défi démographique qui est absolument
majeur qui est devant nous un vrai
bouleversement en vérité démographique
et ça veut dire qu'il faut nous y
préparer dès maintenant parce que si
nous manquons la marche dans les deux
années qui viennent c'est certain notre
pays ne sera pas prêt pour ça on a
plusieurs niveaux de réponse on a les
annonces qui ont été faites avec la
première ministre de soutien au
département et qui a été voté ici à
l'unanimité au Sénat dans le cadre du
PLFSS 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaire dès 2024 pour qu'aucun
département ne soit compensé à moins de
40 % de ses dépenses en perte
d'autonomie et une refonte majeure de
l'ensemble des fonds de concours que
nous engageons en coconstruction avec
les départements et vous l'avez dit la
question de la grande loi je sais pas si
elle est grande mais en tout cas la loi
de programmation que nous devons
coconstruire j'ai proposé une méthode
sur cette loi de programmation consulter
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
représentés à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat l'ensemble des associations
d'élus l'ensemble des acteurs du grand
âge y compris les personnes directement
concernées pour qu'on évite aussi
parfois de parler à leur place et cette
loi de programmation elle est évidemment
pluriannuelle et elle doit poser des
questions clés la question de la
gouvernance évidemment quels sont les
périmètres quelles sont les compétences
comment les organiser quelle
architecture voulons-nous la question
des moyens je crois que nous serons tous
d'accord pour dire qu'il y aura besoin
de moyens supplémentaires peut-être
aurons-nous des désaccords sur quel
levier actionner pour que ce soit
possible en tout cas il faut que tout
soit mis sur la table sans aucun tabout
sans aucun totem puisque l'idée c'est
vraiment qu'on arrive à coconstruire une
vraie loi de programmation pluriannuelle
pour relever le défi du grand âge et
vous l'avez vu à l'Assemblée nationale
la proposition loi bien vieillir a été
adoptée très largement elle sera
rapidement en examen au Sénat et elle
répond notamment à certains des enjeux
sociétaux je pense à la question du
droit de visite opposable pour les
familles et je pense notamment à la
question des professionnels la meilleure
reconnaissance et revalorisation des
professionnels bref je crois qu'on a une
belle feuille de route qui je l'espère
sera partagé et qu'en tout cas je
souhaite coconstruire avec vous je vous
remercie madame guilz
oui madame la ministre vous l'avez
souligné un actif sur qu pratiquement he
seraidant en 2030 et plus de 20 % des
travailleurs auront été obligés de
s'absenter du travail pour s'occuper
d'un proche alors moi j'ai un autre
souci parce que c'est vrai qu'on dit
beaucoup de pourcentage beaucoup de
chiffres mais mon inquiétude est surtout
sur le personnel comment allons-nous
trouver le personnel qui manque il y a
un tel pourcentage et je dirais partout
dans les hôpitaux que ça soit chez les
aidans et cetera comment nous allons
faire
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Mara de
Sidr pour le groupe les
républicain Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre le 22
novembre 2023 est une date noire pour
l'économie circulaire en Europe après
plusieurs mois de débat la proposition
du règlement emballage a été adoptée par
le Parlement européen mais dans une
version largement amoindri par rapport
au texte initial proposé par la
Commission pour le Sénat qui a tant Ré à
lutter contre contre le toutjetable à
améliorer nos performances de prévention
et de gestion des déchets à l'occasion
de la loi AGC notamment c'est une très
grande déception mais cette déception
Estelle partagée par le gouvernement et
par votre majorité permettez-moi d'en
douter en effet qu'elle ne fut pas ma
surprise de voir que la consigne pour
recyclage des bouteilles en plastique
avait été adopté par le Parlement avec
l'aide notamment des députés européens
Renaissance cette même consigne dont
nous avions eu collectivement la sagesse
de repousser la mise en œuvre cette même
consigne à laquelle vous ministre de
l'écologie vous êtes opposé de manière
éloquente monsieur le ministre reprenant
au demeurant point par point les
arguments de notre rapport d'information
de juillet dernier peut-être alors
faut-il chercher l'origine de ce soutien
du côté de l'Élysée le président de la
République semble avoir fait de la
consigne pour recyclage le nouvel avatar
de son marketing écologique la BAL est
désormais dans le camp du conseil et il
vous faudra alors sortir de l' ambigé
monsieur le ministre au sujet de cette
consigne pour recyclage la voix de la
France sera-t-elle celle de son ministre
de la transition écologique vous ou
celle de l'Élysée je vous remercie pour
vous répondre la parole et au ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Martha
Sidrac vous avez évoqué ce vote au
Parlement européen en regrettant
certaines positions issu du groupe
je pourrais vous dire que mes regrets
sur l'amoindrissement de l'ambition sont
aussi liés à des votes qui ont été
obtenus par beaucoup de voix issu du PPE
pour en amoindrir une portée de
l'ambition et de la portée mais au-delà
du texte revenons à l'objet de votre
question qui est la question de la
consigne et en particulier non pas de
cette consigne pour réemploi mais de
cette consigne pour recyclage puisque
c'est bien là que la difficulté porte
vous avez été
l'auteur sous la houlette du président
l'jau d'une mission flash le 11 juillet
dernier avec 28 propositions dans
plusieurs dénonçant le caractère
économiquement irrationnel de la
consigne insistant sur les effets
pervers environnementaux de ce
dispositif et du fait qu'on finissait
par se détourner avec un objectif de
taux de recyclage de la véritable
ambition qui doit être la réduction de
la mise sur le marché de ce plastique
ces positions elles sont les miennes je
les a exprimé lors des Assises des
déchets fin septembre la consigne pour
recyclage ne figure pas dans le cahier
des charges de la Rep emballage que j'ai
transmis à l'ensemble des parties
prenantes qui fait l'objet à l'heure
actuelle de débat et qui ne prévoit
qu'un dispositif de préfiguration de
consigne régional si certains
territoires qui sont très en retard
décident de combler ce retard de cette
manière parce que je vous rappelle que
derrière des statistiques nationales
nous varions aujourd'hui entre des taux
de collecte qui en fonction des
territoires s'échelonnent entre 40 et 90
% et dans ce domaine nos villes ont à
copieré les performances des campagnes
de manière gén is et du Grand Ouest de
manière générale la Vendé le Méloir et
une partie du grand est également quid
de ce sujet je n'ai pas deux positions
j'irai le 18 décembre dire que la
position de la France n'est pas
favorable à la généralisation d'une
consigne pour recyclage pour exactement
les mêmes raisons que celles que je suis
en train de vous indiquer la seule
limite c'est que vous appeliez vous-même
dans votre mission flash à ce qu'en 2026
on a une clause de revoyure si on avit
pas suffisamment progressé c'est en
terme de collecte le texte de la
Commission européenne en vrai n'est pas
très loin du rapport Martha de Sidrac
mais je défendrai le principe de
mobiliser tous les leviers pas pour la
consigne pour
recyclage madame de Sidrac alors
monsieur le ministre c'est bien c'est
bien c'est rassurant de dire quelle est
votre position mais on aimerait que
cette position là soit défendue au
moment du conseil c'est ça qui est
important aujourd'hui mais pas
simplement pour que vous vous contentiez
de donner votre avis parce que ce qu'il
faut avoir en tête véritablement c'est
que en réalité les bouteilles en
plastique représentent 3 % en fait de
notre bac jaune or c'est les 97 % du
reste de notre bac jaune qui nous
pénalise par rapport à nos objectifs
européens et cela nous coûte plus d'un
milliard d'euros donc cela doit être
véritablement défendu par notre
gouvernement français au sein du conseil
avec cette position et je vous remercie
de de la rappeler dans cette instance
merci très bien
la parole est à notre collègue adelziane
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre chers
collègues ma question porte sur le
diagnostic posé tout récemment par le
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
puisque c'est avec beaucoup d'intérêt
mais énormement une grande perplexité
que nous avons pris connaissance de ces
propos samedi dernier dans la presse où
enfin a été évoqué dans le débat actuel
le rôle déterminant joué par
l'immigration dans la prospérité
économique de notre pays dans les 10
années à venir je le cite la France aura
sans doute besoin d'avoir recours à
l'immigration car 1300000 emplois seront
à pourvoir rien que dans le secteur de
l'industrie du fait des départs à la
retraite 100000 à 200000 personnes
venant le de l'étranger pourrait être
nécessaire pour réindustrialiser notre
pays et encore c'est une estimation
basse il faudrait dans le même temps que
notre pays soit capable de former dans
ce secteur 800000 à 900000 jeunes et
moins jeunes ma question est simple
comment compte le gouvernement opérer
pour répondre à ces besoins pharaoniques
et vitaux pour notre économie alors que
en même temps le projet de loi
immigration dans sa forme actuelle et
c'est un euphémisme réduira
considérablement le rayonnement
l'attractivité de notre pays auprès des
travailleurs et des étudiants
étrangers madame
agrestiach merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Zian merci de
m'interroger sur la situation euh en
réalité des travailleurs immigrés dans
notre pays on va démarrer par ça vous
savez le projet de loi que porte le
gouvernement est actuellement examiné en
commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale après avoir après avoir été
voté ici au Sénat le gouvernement reste
attaché à ce que les étrangers qui
participent à la vitalité de notre
économie et de notre pays puisse être
régularisé selon des modalités qui
doivent encore être définies au cours
des discussions et de la discussion
parlementaire à venir particulièrement
dans les secteurs en tension les
étrangers vivent et travaillent parfois
depuis très longtemps en France sous
l'autorité de patron qui refuse souvent
de les régulariser nous souhaitons
mettre fin à ce servage moderne en
permettant ses régularisations grâce à
ce projet de loi car comme vous nous
sommes convaincus que le travail demeure
un facteur d'intégration puissant des
étrangers Primot arrivants il est de
notre devoir de garantir les meilleures
conditions d'intégration à celles et
ceux qui ont notamment obtenu l'asile
dans notre pays comme l'a rappelé le
ministre de l'Intérieur il faut être dur
avec les étrangers D 5 ans et mieux
intégrer ceux qui veulent travailler
c'est ce que nous faisons avec ce projet
de loi qui est en cours au Parlement et
qui reviendra probablement en commission
mixte paritaire merci
beaucoup monsieur zan
oui merci Madame madame toutefois votre
réponse confirme malheureusement
l'isolement et la dissonance de cette
analyse portée par le ministre délégué à
l'Industrie puisque en responsabilité le
projet de loi immigration intégration
qui aurait nous auraitû faire émerger
une vision stratégique et globale de ces
questions car oui la France aura un
besoin impératif de travailleurs
étrangers au risque de connaître une
régression économique majeure qui va
dégrader notre prospérité notre
attractivité notre influence nous sommes
déjà affectés nous étions le 4e pays
d'accueil pour les étudiants nous sommes
le 6e dépassé par l'Allemagne estalonné
par le Japon les délis de trraitements
des dossiers vont s'allonger et
décourager les demandeurs et enfin sur
la question des départs à la retraite
c'est une proposition de baisse de la
durée d'indemnisation chômage des plus
de 55 ans qui a été émise agents de
sécurité médecins aide soignante
vétérinaire emploi agricole cette France
qui se lève tôt voire très tôt contribue
à la richesse nationale quand d'autres
pays font le choix d'une politique
volontairement intégratrice le projet de
loi immigration prépare le déclassement
économique de notre pays il est à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui il est
temps de rectifier le tir
encore la parole est à notre collègue
Didier Mandelli pour le groupe des
républiques merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé elle concerne
également le ministre de l'Intérieur et
celui de la transition écologique il y a
un an le gouvernement créé dans le cadre
du projet de loi de finance contre la
vie du Sénat un nouveau jeu d'argent sur
le Motel du Loto du patrimoine le lotau
de la biodiversité je dois rappeler que
sur 15 € dépensés pour un ticket
patrimoine 1,52 € seulement revienent à
la Fondation pour le ticket mission
nature le coût est de 3 € pour un
reversement de 43 centimes à l'office
Fran de la biodiversité un don en direct
à des associations aurait permis à
l'acheteur du ticket de bénéficier d'une
réduction d'impôt de 66 % et
d'accompagner vraiment celle-ci au-delà
des aspects financiers la question de
l'addiction est centrale le nombre de
joueurs addictes en France a doublé en
10 an plus de 400000 un/ers des ados jou
c'est un véritable problème de santé
publique et la mise de 3 € pour le jeu
mission nature très accessible pour les
jeunes très sensible à la cause
environnementale est une incitation
malsine comment l'État peut-il
participer directement et aussi
cyniquement à ce scandale sanitaire
comment le président de la République
peut-il s'ériger en VRP de la Française
des Jeux le weekend dernier dans le Jura
verrons-nous demain par votre
gouvernement la création de nouveau jeux
de loto pour palier aux carences des
politiques publiques je vous suggère
dans ce cas le loto du handicap le lotau
du gantage le lotau des maladies rares
le lotau des soins palliatif et à terme
pourquoi pas le lotau de la prévention
des addictions notamment au jeux et puis
en conclusion pourquoi l'État a-t-il
financé la campagne de publicité de ce
jeu dans la presse quotidienne régionale
quel est le coût de cette campagne de
communication et tout simplement est-ce
légal on vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la Santé de la
[Applaudissements]
préventionérêt en fonction de ce que le
gouvernement me
donnesieur le président merci Monsieur
le le sénateur de cette question qui qui
s'adressait à trois ministres alors je
je vais je vais répondre le premier vous
avez vous avez tout à fait raison de
souligner vous avez tout à fait raison
de de souligner que les addictions ce ne
sont pas que les addictions aux
substances comme l'on dit et qu'il y a
des des addictions sans substance il y a
les addictions aux écrans il y a les
addictions aux jeu et vous avez vous
avez raison de souligner que ça fait
cela fait partie des objectifs que doit
avoir dans toute politique de santé
publique de réduire ces addictions parce
que si vous permettez l'expression on
finit toujours par payer l'addiction
mais je je voudrais je voudrais
souligner que on ne peut pas mettre
absolument tous les sujets on ne peut
pas mettre tous les sujets sur le même
plan et quand on est dans un dispositif
qui a une vocation ciblée le patrimoine
la
biodiversité que on sait par ailleurs
que ce sont des opérations ponctuelles
accompagnées on ne peut pas être là dans
le même dans la même approche exactement
que celle qu'on peut avoir par exemple
sur un jeu d'argent sur un jeu d'argent
sur sur les écrans vidéos on doit
effectivement être prudent et je je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le fait de dire
que le le c'est l'OTO ne doivent pas
devenir une norme qui semblerait être
une une nouvelle façon de financer des
politiques publqu
mais il y a aussi dans dans cela un
moyen pour les Français de dire leur
engagement sur des sur des sujets
auxquels ils tiennent et je crois que
c'est d'abord ça qu'il faut retenir et
je pense que le nombre de Français qui
sont addictes au jeu et réel beaucoup
moins ceux qui sont strictement addictes
au loto du patrimoine ou à celui de la
biodiversité merci monsieur le
sénateur monsieur
Mandelli oui monsieur le ministre vot
répon certes complète mais ne me
satisfait pas c'est un jeu donc ce jeu
peut générer une addiction tout
simplement et vous n'avez pas répondu à
ma question sur le financement de la
campagne de promotion et de
communication qui revient logiquement la
Française des jeux des fonds publics qui
servent à financer un jeu organisé par
la française je suis désolé ça n'a pas
lieu
d'être la parole est à notre collègue
jean-jac Panzi pour le groupe les
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la Corse est frappé de plein
fouet par une épidémie de fièvre catara
Lovine qui décime les troupeaux 1000
breobis mortes dont 500 en une semaine
une mortalité élevée mais aussi une
morbidité importante avec des pertes
d'agneaux et de lait notre île connaît
cette maladie depuis 2001 mais c'est la
première fois qu'elle est confrontée au
variant 8 particulièrement virulant
lorsqu'on regarde la carte des type en
Europe on s'aperçoit que ce variant 8
qui touche aujourd'hui la Corse n'existe
qu'en France continentale il y a donc
une double faille dans le processus
d'une part au niveau des exploitations
infestées d'où vient la fièvre alors
qu'il y a obligation de déclaration pour
que le virus ne quitte pas le territoire
et se propage au-delà et d'autre part au
niveau des ports d'accès à la Corse à
Marseille ou au sein d'un port insulaire
où le contrôle sanitaire a fait défaut
les conséquences doivent être mesurées
avec justesse monsieur le ministre nous
disposons d'une AOP pour le Brot qui
impose à ce qu'il ce que le lait soit
issu de la race auovine endémique qui ne
compte que 80000 tête quand une partie
du chaptel est dessinée il s'agit de
renouveler facilement par achat pour
maintenir laop miser sur la reproduction
le parcours est long et se met d' bûche
monsieur le ministre si la prise en
charge du vaccin a été réglée par les
services préfectoraux et la collectivité
de Corse l'indemnisation des animaux
morts ou atteints de morbidité reste en
suspens les pistes avancées par vos
services enc sont bien en dessà des
besoins en pleine épidémie on ne peut
pas raisonner à enveloppe fermée tout
simplement parce qu'on ne connaît pas
encore l'étendue des dégâts et le nombre
de têtes à indemniser le mode de
financement celui retenu par la règle
des minimi capé à 20000 € sur 3 ans pour
les agriculteurs est inadapté et prédit
une indemnisation au rabais la seule
voie d'indemnisation possible est celle
du règlement général d'exemption par
catégorie qui permet aux États membres
d'octroyer des aides après notification
à Bruxelles bien sûr pour faire face à
des impomérables en l'occurrence une
épidémie qui dessine à rassaui une corps
sur laquelle repose une AOP et donc
toute une activité rurale qui ne saurait
subsister sans une volonté de votre part
monsieur le ministre êtes-vous prêt à
vous engager en ce sens pour vous
répondre la Paro au porte-parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
mesames les sénatrices messieurs les les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jean-Jacques palounzi merci pour votre
question je réponds à la place de Marc
fen vous aurez remarqué que je le
remplace aujourd'hui la fièvre catarale
ovine également appelée la maladie de la
langue bleue où je messille à l'anglais
le Blue tong est une maladie virale qui
touche les ruminants sauvages et
domestiques les ins les B vins et même
les caprins c'est une maladie qui a
impacté à plusieurs reprises le
territoire national c'est 10 dernières
années elle n'a strictement elle est
strictement animale elle n'affecte pas
l'homme elle n'a aucune incidence sur la
qualité sanitaire des denrées que ce
soit la la viande ou le lait toutefois
vous l'avez souligné ces répercussions
économiques peuvent être importantes
directement parce que les animaux
infectés peuvent présenter des signes
cliniques ou indirectement par la
fermeture de marchés étrangers de
nombreux foyers cliniques de fièvre
catarale ovine stérotype 8 sont constaté
dans des élevages depuis début août 2023
sur le territoire métropolitain plus de
1630 foyers sont aujourd'hui recensés
dont près de 900 dans l'avyon la
vaccination c'est un outil de prévention
et de lutte qui permet de protéger le
cheptel et son voisinage la vaccination
elle est volontaire l'éleveur peut
vacciner directement ses animaux en
revanche si la vaccination doit être
justifiée et certifiée elle doit alors
être réalisée par un vétérinaire la
règlementation européenne prévoit que
les mesures de prévention et de lutte
relève de la responsabilité de la
profession agricole c'est pourquoi
l'État n'a généralement pas vocation à
prendre en charge le coût de la
vaccination ni indemniser les pertes
économiques induites par cette maladie
les organisations professionnelles
agricoles se sont organisé rapidement
pour établir un document de
recommandation aux éleveurs
l'introduction du virus en Corse est
particulièrement récente on recens
actuellement une vingtaine de foyers
confirmés de stéréotype 8 et 3 de
stérotype 4 l'impact sur le chaptel
Corse reste donc modéré en nombre de
foyers la situation é remontée par le
préfet de Corse au ministère de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire qui est très mobilisé ils m
l'ont dit ils suivent la situation les
demandes portées par les professionnels
sont en cours d'examen au niveau local
et au niveau national une réponse vous
sera livré
bientôt monsieur
palonzi la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Christopher Zurek pour la
Réunion administrative les sénateurs ne
figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mes chers
collègues l'explosion de l'insécurité
que connaît la France si dramatique
soit-elle ne doit pas nous détourner de
la catastrophe économique et sociale que
nous traversons à ce titre la litanie
statistique est loquante 32 % des
Français ne sont pas en capacité de se
procurer une alimentation saine et en
qualité suffisante pour manger trois
repas par jour 15 % des Français sautent
des repas 43 % déclarent avoir des
difficultés pour manger des fruits et
légumes frais quotidiennement en un an
le prix des énergies a connu une
augmentation moyenne de 23 % et à partir
de février 2024 ce sera encore 10 %
d'augmentation du prix de l'électricité
contre les promesses de Bruno lumer
lui-même pendant ce temps le prix moyen
du carburant ne passe plus en dessous
sous du seuil franchi il y a maintenant
plus d'un an de 1,80 € la conséquence de
cette inflation incontrôlée c'est
l'aggravation de l'appauvrissement de
nos compatriotes avec un taux de
pauvreté aujourd'hui de 15 % de la
population française soit 10 millions de
personnes le bilan du gouvernement est
catastrophique et alors que le froid
arrive 44 % des Français disent se
priver de chauffage quand on a de
l'argent on fait des choix quand on en a
plus on fait des sacrifices monsieur le
ministre mon discours n'est pas
misérabiliste il n'est qu'un reflet de
ce que vivent les Français rien ne
s'améliore mais tout s'aggrave et aucune
des politiques que vous menez n'inverse
la tendance car tout n'est que
cataplasme pardon quand c'est un
changement profond de système dont nous
avons besoin le gouvernement pêche par
orgueil en refusant de voir la réalité
du drame économique et social que nous
vivons et du déclassement français que
nous traversons vous allez me répondre
comme d'habitude que les causes de ce
marasme sont conjoncturelles nous
pensons qu'elles sont aussi structurell
la crise sanitaire et les conflits
internationaux ne peuvent pas être une
éternelle réponse à tout la réalité
c'est que vous ne maîtrisez rien que
vous ne faites que du fléchage
budgétaire quand nos compatriotes
demandent aux politiques de prendre les
choses en main et de faire autre chose
que du rafistolage monsieur le ministre
nous entrons dans l'hiver et les fêtes
de Noël et de fin d'année approche alors
qu'alz-vous laisser entrevoir pour nos
compatriotes la lumière au bout du
tunnel ou le coup prê au-dessus du
billot merci la pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre délégué Jean-Noël
barreot en charge numérique monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
Zurek le coût de la vie est un sujet qui
préoccupe le gouvernement qui agit pour
apporter des réponses à nos concitoyens
activement depuis 2 ans si la France
fait partie monsieur le sénateur des
quelques pays en Europe qui a le mieux
résisté à l'inflation ça n'est pas le
fruit du hasard ni celui de l'opération
du Saint-Esprit c'est parce que le
gouvernement a veillé à réduire les
dépenses contraintes et à lever les
revenus et en particulier les les petits
revenus à à réduire les les dépenses
contraintes avec le bouclier énergie
avec l'chque carburant avec l'extension
sur proposition du Sénat du titre
restaurant à toutes les denrées
alimentaires avec le plafonnement de la
hausse des loyers ou avec encore le
maintien des prix à l'université que ce
soit pour les loyers ou la restauration
au cru ou encore les frais d'inscription
et puis relever les revenus et en
particulier les plus revenus avec la les
petits revenus pardon avec la
revalorisation du SMIC la revalorisation
euh des enseignants la revalorisation
des personnel soignants et du personnel
du médico-social la la revalorisation
des stagiaires et des boursiers je
n'entends pas beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur de de de proposition dans votre
question mais sachez que nous avons sous
l'autorité de la première ministre un
cap qui est très clair celui de
poursuivre les réformes pour faire en
sorte de donner à chacun de nos
concitoyens notamment la possibilité
d'avoir un emploi et je note que les
politiques que nous avons mené depuis 7
ans portent leurs fruit puisque en
France et notamment dans votre
département le chômage recule il a
reculé d'ailleurs de trois points dans
votre département c'est plus que la
moyenne nationale et vous conviendrez
avec moi monsieur le sénateur que la
meilleure garantie de revenus c'est
l'emploi et c'est ce à quoi nous
employons avec le
gouvernement
merci nous en avons terminé avec les
questions au Gouvernement les prochaines
auront lieu le mercredi 13 décembre
13 décembre du fait du vote du budget je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à
16h35 pour l'examen du projet de loi de
finances considéré comme adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale en application de
l'article 49 al 3 de la Constitution la
séance est
suspendue